you want to avoid making a train wreck
out of your life as a man
and one of the best ways that you can
avoid making a train wreck out of your
life
is being able to identify the winners
from the losers
okay and the quicker that you can adapt
that skill
into your toolbox you know the sooner
you can take that tool and drop it in
your toolbox and you have it readily
accessible to you
you can do that at 30 it's better than
you know the time that it took for me to
do it because i probably started this
around my mid 30s
late 30s but 25 20 the sooner you can
get these skill sets
at identifying these things than
optimizing at them
you're going to be flying in life you
know you'll be where i am today
in your early 30s or maybe even late 20s
if you do it right
um there's a lot of guys out there that
are
that are that are making way too many
concessions with their life
way too many mistakes allowing dummies
to dictate and run their lives
and they just suffer with it it's you
know it's insufferable to see some of
the
tales and listen to some of the stories
that you hear and it's like why are you
carrying around all this nonsense when
all you got to do is cut the anchor
loose bro
but people love you know people love to
complicate their lives and then justify
why they do it
some people wandering around doing the
same thing over over and
again every single day is a cog in a
wheel and they hate it it's like what do
i do next and i don't know what to do
and i'm just stuck
and it's like dude in the absence of
clarity do something
right move towards something else leave
behind whatever you're at if you got to
paddle the boat because there's no wind
in your sail
paddle the boat to where you got to get
to where the trade winds are at and let
your sails fill with wind god damn it
start moving in the right direction
as a guy it's incumbent upon you
you have the burden of performance
that's what that's what men have to do
you have to make yourself
um you know some guys get silver spooned
um you know the best deal of their life
most people don't the people that don't
that make something out of their life
that's long-lasting the silver spoon
crowd they don't last too long i've
never seen them last too long anyway
you